Bitte schön.
Hallo, Leile ist mein Name und ich bin eine der Stationsärzte.
Und heute bin ich für Sie zuständig.
Ich würde dieses Aufnahmegespräch durchführen, weil Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir und hilft mir.
Okay, und jetzt werde ich einfach fragen, zu Ihren Personen stellen.
Und danach werden wir sofort Ihre aktuelle Beschreibung sprechen.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiß Martin Müller.
Martin Müller.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 89, das sieht man mir nicht an.
99.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 1,65, das wird ja auch alles ein bisschen weniger.
Ich bin 60.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege noch 60 Kilo, das ist nicht mehr viel dran an mir.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Und was fehlt sich zu uns?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche Schmerzen in meinem rechten Bein,
so im Ohrschenke, so an der Hüfte.
Wissen Sie, ich bin heute morgen irgendwie umgefallen.
Und dann, seither tut es richtig doll weh, das habe ich doch auch klar.
Heute haben Sie umgefahren.
Ja, ich bin hingestürzt.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, das wird schon wieder besser
und ich kann mich bestimmt nachher wieder bewegen.
Das ist immer schlechter geworden.
Und dann konnte ich mich nachher irgendwie kaum noch bewegen.
Und dann habe ich schließlich meine Tochter angerufen, die wohnt nicht weit weg.
Und die hat mich dann hier zum Krankenhaus gebracht.
Das war ein bisschen nackt, mich in das Auto reinzukriegen.
Aber wir hatten Rollstuhl, da hatte ich noch von meiner Frau.
Und deswegen ging das.
Okay, und wann genau ist das passiert?
Das war so gegen 10 Uhr oder so?
Ungefähr 10 Stunden her.
Ja, erst habe ich gedacht, ich lege mich noch mal hin
und dann wird es schon wieder, aber es ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Und ja, haben Sie nur Ihre, ja, noch haben Sie die linke Seite?
Die rechte Seite.
Okay.
Und haben Sie diese Hüftgelenkschmerzen
oder haben Sie auch noch eine andere Sicherheit?
Ja, das tut der, also das tut da einer Seite weh
und das strahlt aber auch so ein bisschen in den Oberschenkel rein.
Und ich nehme an, ich habe dann einen tüchtigen blauen Fleck.
Aber ich kann mir das ja alleine nicht angucken.
Und weil ich das jetzt gar nicht mehr so richtig bewegen kann
und gar nicht mehr laufen kann, habe ich gedacht,
ich muss wohl doch mal zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus kommen.
Okay.
Und ja, in diesem rechten Unterhörngeläder,
fühlen Sie sich alles noch?
Haben Sie gefühltlosigkeit, Taub als Gefühl?
Ja, so ein bisschen taub ist das rechte Bein.
Haben Sie das rechte, das linke Bein ist okay?
Sonst hätte ich ja gar nicht irgendwie zu Recht kommen können,
aber das rechte Bein ist jetzt so ein bisschen kribbelig, ja, und taub.
Ist ein bisschen belässert geworden?
Hab ich nicht drauf geachtet?
Also ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, oder ist schon kaltiger Gefühl, haben Sie in diesem Leiter?
Die Kälte würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, ne?
Okay.
Und können Sie Ihre rechte Füße bewegen oder rechte Zehen bewegen?
Also ich kann das wohl ein bisschen bewegen, aber es tut irrsinnig weh.
Also wenn ich Ruhe gebe, dann geht es, ja,
aber wenn ich versuche, irgendwas an den Beinen zu bewegen,
tut es sehr weh.
Okay, aber hauptsächlich bewegen zu können, ja.
Wenn Sie das schaffen können, ja, das können wir sicher sein,
dass die Nerven noch nicht beeinträchtig sind.
Und, okay, Herr Müller.
Und, ja, haben Sie Fieber oder?
Oh, habe ich nicht gemessen, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber hab.
Ne, ich bin ja auf die Hinterangefeile, also Fieber habe ich nicht.
Okay, in den letzten Zeiten ungewirbt, aber dazu genommen.
Ne, ich glaube, ich fiege über gleich viel.
Ja, da tut sich ja nicht mehr viel in meinem Alter.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stöhrang?
Na ja, also nachts muss ich schon mal auf die Tonne, das ist ja klar, ne?
Okay, und so, setzlich, arbetiert Ihrer Partit,
ist in Ordnung, wie ist Ihrer Partit?
Ja, also, wenn ich denn was habe, dann schmeckt mir das auch wohl, ja.
Okay, und ja, leiten Sie an Krönchenerkrankungen und auch auf der Erkrankung?
Jede Menge, ist doch klar in meinem Alter, wer ist da schon gesund, ne?
Ja, also, dass das Herz nicht so ganz 100%ig ist, das weiß ich.
Und dann habe ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, das habe ich schon lange.
Und dann hat man auch mal festgestellt, dass ich Osteoporose habe, ja, das also, ne?
Und dann hatte ich vor, ah, das ist gar nicht so lange her.
Vor vier Jahren hatte ich mal eine Thrombose in den Beinen.
Vor vier Jahren Thrombose.
Ja, und dann hat man natürlich auch noch mal festgestellt, dass meine Schilddrüse nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Jetzt muss ich immer so Schilddrüsen-Tabletten nehmen.
Das ist aber schon, ja, schon eine Weile her, fünf Jahre oder so, ne?
Und in letzter Zeit, also, ja, eigentlich schon seit Jahren habe ich immer ein bisschen Husten, immer so trockenen Husten.
Okay, und was für Medikamente nehmen Sie ein, regelmäßig?
Ja, also einmal nämlich dieses für die Schilddrüse, dann nehme ich eine morgens, ich weiß aber nicht, wie das heißt.
Dann kann Ihnen, also...
Dann gucken Sie, was das könnte sein?
Das könnte sein, dass das so heißt, ja.
Und dann nehme ich eine Aspirin morgens, diese Aspirin, ein 100, die man immer so nehmen soll.
Und dann habe ich noch Omeprazol und Metoprolol, das weiß ich.
Okay, nur diese vier?
Ja, nur die vier, genau.
Und jetzt, weil das so weh getan hat, habe ich dann von den Aspirin, das ist ja auch gegen Schmerzen gut, habe ich noch ein paar mehr genommen,
aber das hat nicht so wirklich viel geholfen.
Okay, und ja, nur eine Frage noch, können Sie diese Masse noch mehr aushalten?
Ja, wenn Sie nicht bewegen, können Sie...
Wenn ich mich nicht bewegige, dass ich echt darf, nur nicht rumlaufen oder mit dem Bein zappeln, dann tut es weh.
Okay, und sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Das ist aber schon lange her, als ich kurz vor der Rente war, da hat man mal die Krampfadern operiert, an beiden Beinen.
Und dann hatte ich mal so eine Stelle an der Backe hier im Gesicht, das hieß Basaliom, das hat man rausgemacht.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich... bin ich bisher ganz gut klarkommen.
In dieser Varezenentfernung, in welchem Bein war das?
Dann waren beide Beine da dran.
Beide Beine.
Okay.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht, das meines war auch, warum ich so alt geworden bin.
Okay, das ist ja gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach, ich trinke gerne mal ein Gläschen Sekt.
Das mache ich schon häufiger mal, so 2-3 Mal in der Woche gibt es ein Gläschen Sekt.
Und wenn es was zu feiern gibt, natürlich.
Okay.
Und, ja, das ist...
Solltet sich das nicht?
Haben Sie aller G?
Oh, bisher wüsste ich das nicht.
Das hätte man ja wahrscheinlich inzwischen gemerkt.
Also ich habe keine aller G.
Oder ich bin eine Unverträglichkeit gegen Nahrungsmittel oder so.
Weißt du, das ist auch ein...
Ja, ich glaube, ich kann alles essen, was ich will.
Okay.
Und, ja, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Das wäre ja gut und wundern, wenn die noch am Leben sind.
Okay, und woran sind Sie gestorben?
Wunderbar, dass ich noch am Leben bin.
Bitte?
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Ach, ich weiß gar nicht.
Mein Vater, der war einfach nur alt.
Und bei meiner Mutter, da weiß ich, dass die Brustkrebs hatte.
Aber sonst, das ist schon so lange her, liebe Güte, ja.
Ja, Ihre Mutter hatte Brustkrebs, weshalb?
Aha, dann ist sie gestorben.
Okay.
Und, ja, sind Sie in Rente jetzt?
Ja, ja, klar.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Töchter.
Mhm.
Alle sind gesund, oder?
Ja, die eine, die hatte tatsächlich jetzt eine Hirnblutung.
Und hat es aber, das ist wohl ganz gut gegangen.
Sie hat wohl Glück gehabt.
Das ist alles wieder so weit hergestellt, aber die müssen natürlich auf sich aufpassen.
Mhm.
Und die anderen zwei sind gesund.
Die beiden anderen sind noch viel, ich weiß gesund, ja.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und sind Sie verreiheratet?
Ich bin verwittet.
Okay.
Und, Herr Müller,
jetzt alle meine wichtige Fragen habe ich schon gestellt.
Und wenn Sie etwas hinzufügen möchten, kann ich gerne hören.
Und, ja, also ich habe mir ja jede Menge erzählt.
Mhm.
Also, wenn Sie Fragen haben, kann ich gerne antworten.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, ja, kann ich gerne antworten.
Ja, also ich will jetzt eigentlich nur wissen, was kann man denn jetzt machen dagegen?
Und wenn es denn da sein, dass es mit einmal Sodolvetut
und muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Ja, jetzt sollen Sie hier bleiben.
Ja, damit wir alles nachtlos organisieren können.
Und ja, dann,
vielleicht brauchen wir eine Operation für diesen Ereignis.
Ja, da Sie schon eine Operation in meinem Alter, das ist doch bestimmt gefährlich, oder?
Ja, leider so.
Das sollen wir zusammen einmal sitzen und sprechen, wie die Gefähre sind
und wie können wir diese Situation umgehen
und ja, wenn wir danach eine richtige Entscheidung treffen, ich glaube.
Vielleicht habe ich ja Glück und es muss doch nicht operiert werden.
Ich bin sehr fehlheit, aber sie haben jetzt eine Osterporose-Geschichte
und ja, bei solchen Fällen, kein, eine Knochenbruch ist immer fraglich.
Wo meinst du, dass wir gebrochen sind?
Oh, ja, das wäre natürlich blöd, ja.
Ja, das haben jetzt,
werde ich die Köfer unterseuchen
und danach ja, ein paar bildgebende Verfahren sollen wir veranlassen
und dann können wir alles ausgelieht danach sprechen.
Ja, aber ich muss nichts tun, ich muss nur hier einfach liegen bleiben, ne?
Ja, ich.
Ich kann einfach hier liegen bleiben, ne?
Das ist gut, ja.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt, ja.
Ich muss nicht laufen.
Ja.
Ich habe einen Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen,
aber erst mal ich habe eine Sache sagen.
Unsere Patiente 89 Jahre alt ist, ist es notwendig,
dass das Herz-Kraw-Fluid-System und Neurologische-System genaues befragen,
weil nicht nur zum Beispiel Koks-Krama, aber warum hingesüst,
eine Syncopa, eine Syncopa vor dem Unfall, nach dem Unfall, das Beus sein,
oder andere, ja.
Ja, tatsächlich, tatsächlich ist dem Patienten, bevor er umgefallen ist,
schwindelig geworden.
Insofern genau richtig, ja, genau.
Guter Hinweis.
Dann, ja, diese Geschichte, ja, frage ich einfach noch.
Ja, das können Sie am Dreiehmester gut.
Klar, der hat noch jemand anderes, andere Fragen.
Es kam, glaube ich, einmal jetzt so, eingeblendet die Frage nach der Schmerzintensität, ne?
Hat irgendjemand gefragt.
Das haben Sie, die Schmerzgala haben Sie nicht abgefragt.
Der Patient hat gesagt, Flakkant, Flakkant.
Wir, was hat er gesagt?
Blaufläcke.
Das ist ja, äkimoze.
Ja, können wir diese genau beschreiben zum Beispiel?
Ja, die Wege raus sind die Blaufläcke.
Ja, Hämatons, zum Beispiel, eine Hämatons.
Ja, wobei der hat ja gesagt, er hat das selber nicht gesehen.
Er glaubt, aber er hat blaue Flecken, ne?
Aber wie gesagt, Schmerzintensität, da hat er ja gesagt,
wenn ich mich nicht bewege, geht's.
Aber wenn ich mich bewege, oh, dann ist ganz schlimm.
Da könnte man jetzt Skala abfragen.
Ja.
Er sagt, also hier nach Angaben, 3 von 10 in Ruhe
und 7 von 10 bei Bewegungsversuch.
Ja, genau.
Geht es, wenn man das nicht fragt?
Ja, weil der hat ja gesagt, er hat das selber nicht angeguckt.
Er glaubt das nur.
Ich denke mal, das sind Sachen, die eigentlich jetzt bei der
jungen Untersuchung dann gecheckt werden müssen.
Also was weiß ich, ich denke mal,
neun, achtzigjähriger ist vielleicht nicht so in der Lage,
mal eben schnell seine Rückfront oder so anzugucken, ne?
Können wir erst als Gezieble anfangen?
Wir haben, wir haben nicht gemacht haben.
Was haben wir nicht geschrieben?
Ja, zum Beispiel Sieher, Stechent.
Ach, Schmerzbeschreibung, ja, stimmt.
Geziebister nicht gefragt.
Im Status nicht gefragt.
Oh, oh, ja.
Und Ortopne
Er hat nur gesagt, er hat trockenen Husten hat,
aber sonst hat er nichts gesagt.
Okay.
Aber Sie unterdrücken der Brust,
weil Sie Mama kassieren,
weil sie sind Männer, Martin.
Er ist ein Mann, genau, er ist ein Mann und er ist so alt geworden.
Also ich denke mal, das würde man jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie nachverfolgen.
Okay, ja, vielleicht ja, Frosager untersuchen
oder der regelmäßige Arztkontroll.
Ja, danke.
Ja, davon kann man ja eigentlich ausgehen bei einem Mann
mit so viel Vorerkrankungen
und der kriegt ja auch Medikamente, ne?
Was weiß ich, wenn er, er denkt, das Tyroxin kriegt er ja nicht so.
Da muss er ja auch zum Arzt gehen, ne?
Klackte über Osteophorus und dessen,
viele Probleme.
Okay, können wir...
Er klagt ja eigentlich nicht über die Osteophorose,
sondern er sagt nur, man hat das festgestellt, dass ich das habe.
Ja, und so.
Klagen heißt er eigentlich so selber Beschwerden haben.
Ja.
Reise...
Ja, haben Sie lange weitergeblieben.
Ja, also ich denke mal, das kann man fast vernachlässigen,
wenn man jetzt die Geschichte von den Patienten anguckt.
Ja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der also jetzt noch irgendwie
den großen Hawaii-Urlaub gemacht hat in seinem Alter,
ist irgendwie zu vernachlässigen.
Und er, also nein, er hat keine Reise gemacht.
Und geimpft ist er natürlich gegen Corona, wie alle alten Leute.
Und ja, ne?
Aber das ist natürlich für die Prüfung,
ist das ein wichtiger Punkt, dass Sie das nicht vergessen,
den Impfstatus abzufragen, weil das natürlich heute so was ganz
aktuelles ist, ne?
Nee.
Okay, sollen wir loslegen?
Ja.
Hallo Frau Weizen, ich habe heute einen Patienten,
einen Patienten, einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Herr Martin Müller, 89-Jährige-Patient,
ja, stellte sich bei uns vor, wegen seit,
ja, wegen seit heute bestehenden,
einen rechten Oberschenkelschmerzen.
Und ja, er berichtet über auch einen Sturz,
und die auch heute schon vor zehn Stunden passiert ist.
Und nach dem Sturz hat diese Schmerzen begonnen.
Haben die Schmerzen begonnen?
Ja, haben die Schmerzen begonnen.
Und ja, er berichtet auch, dass er irgendwie Lauflegen haben
können, können.
Und aber genauso, ja, könnte er nicht in diesem Bereich gucken.
Und zusätzlich gibt es auch in der Ruhigerschmerzfreiheit,
aber beim Beweglichen, diese Schmerzen verstärken sich deutlich.
Und die vegetative Anamnese eigentlich jetzt unauffällig
und erleidet an, ja, arterialer Hypertronie
seit vier Jahren aus der Prohose.
Und es ist schon eine tiefen Wenundromose,
festgeschädelt vor vier Jahren, und Hypertrohose,
Hypertrohose, und vor fünf Jahren ist auch schon diagnostiziert.
Und er hat auch eine Druckenerusten.
Und regelmäßig nimmt er Druckziehen und ja,
es gibt 100 Milligramm Aspirin.
Und ja, wegen der Schmerzen,
wegen der Schmerzen hat er ein bisschen ein paar Meter
eingenommen für heute.
Und Omeprosol und Nautaprolar, hat sie auch regelmäßig...
Das gehört zur Dauermedikation.
Dauermedikation.
Und ja, beidseitige Receptomie ist schon durchgeführt
und an Basallium Exzision ist auch in der Vor-
Operation schon bekannt.
Und er raucht nicht und Trinkealcohol,
ja, zweimal wochentlich ein paar Gläsen sägt
und keine bekannte Allergie.
Und seine Mutter ist an eine Brustkrebs gestorben,
Mama Katz nun gestorben.
Und ja, sein Vater ist auch eine...
Ja, der Mannskrankheit kennt man sagen, ich glaube.
Und ja, er ist schon beräntet und hatte drei Töchter
und verwitfert und eine Töchter hatte schon eine Apoplexygeste
und ansonsten die anderen zwei Töchter sind jetzt ganz gesund.
Und ja, unter Berücksuchtigung,
diese anermäßige ich davon aus, dass unser Patient
möglicherweise ein...
Ja, einer...
Okay, aber ich denke, ein Harzbruch hatten könnte.
Deshalb würde ich bei dem Körper hinuntersuchen...
Was wären den Alternativen?
Was könnte es denn, was könnte es denn,
differential yet, must it still be?
Das ist eine...
Ja, auch nach dem Sturz und mit Osterfrossegeschichte
nicht Harzbruch, sondern diese Femurschaftfragtur
kann auf die Frage kommen.
Femurschaft, ja, oder? Was noch?
Und auch diese Hüftgelenkstublization
und auch...
Ja, Pelvicfragturen auch.
Pelvicfragturen...
Ja, genau, eine Weckfragtur, genau, ja, genau.
Gut.
Oder kann ein...
Einfach reichgewebe Muskelverletzung auch...
...Beprelle oder so was.
Hat der Patient denn beschrieben...
...neurologische oder motorische Ausfälle?
Nein, er hat keiner motorische Auffälligkeit berichtet.
Ja, das ist ein Traupeitsgefühl,
ist bei Ihnen schon ein bisschen auffällig geworden.
In rechten Beinen, ansonsten, aber motorischer Funktion.
Schmerzhafter ist schon vorhanden.
Ja, deswegen versucht er das nicht.
Okay, gut.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten jetzt?
Diagnostisch, ja, körperliche Untersuchungen bei diesen...
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Und unterer nächster Demonstraten,
vielleicht Fähnstellung in rechten Beinen,
kann ich einige Hinweise auf Faktoren bekommen.
Genau.
Oder wie groß die Belauflecken oder diese Echemosemotome sind,
kann ich auch bestimmen bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Und auch die Motorität und Motilität.
Und ja, auch...
Sensibilität.
Sensibilität und auch Durchspulutung kann ich auch prüfen.
Die Durchspulutung, ja, das wäre auch interessant.
Dass man guckt, sind die Fußpulse tastbar?
Oder wenn nicht, haben wir ein Doppler-Signal?
Das wäre auch interessant.
Genau.
Was machen Sie?
Muss ich Blut abnehmen unbedingt?
Und wenn wir schon eine Operation planen möchten,
soll ich die Belüftungsparameter darüber etwas wissen unbedingt.
Was müssten Sie denn noch wissen, wenn Sie ihn operieren wollen?
Zusätzlich, ja, aber ich...
Haben Sie ihn gefragt, wann er zuletzt viel Essen hat?
Nein.
Also wenn der OP-Indikation da ist,
wäre das noch eine wichtige Nachfrage,
wann die letzte Mahlzeit war.
Und plus, ja...
Was machen Sie, will ich geben?
Ja, natürlich, in zwei Röntgenbildungen,
in diesem rechten Hüftbereich, würde ich unbedingt machen.
Und ja, hat...
Biletterell oder uniletterell?
Jetzt komme ich in diesem Punkt.
Ja, hat unser Patient...
Ja, hat kein zusätzlicher Bescheid,
schon...
Aber im Autodomal, Biletterell...
Kann man auch dieses Bild geben, der verfahren.
Ja, könnte Biletterell durchführen,
wenn er schon eine austro-prasige Geschichte hat.
Und dann möglicherweise viel, viel...
viele Knochenfragdrucken, wie auch Bestimmen.
Oder, ja, je nach körperlicher Untersuchung,
kann das auch unterschiedlich sein.
Okay, dann...
Gut, was wäre denn im Falle,
dass ich das bestätigt mit der Schenkelhalsfraktur?
Was wäre dann das richtige Vorgehen?
Was würden Sie dann machen?
Okay, ja, in diesem Alter...
Wir haben ja nicht sehr, ob wir
eine totale Hüftbrotterse einsetzen,
so ein...
Diese Operationist-Tür, für ihn könnte sehr gefährlich sein.
Und das können wir richtig einsetzen.
Das ist ja richtig,
wenn diese Hüfttep-Operationen bedürftig ist.
Oder auch, wenn wir konservativ behandeln können.
Ja, genau, wann wäre denn keine Hüfttep erforderlich?
Ich glaube, das ist meine Hausaufgabe.
Ich denke, wenn der Bruch richtig steht,
wenn der richtig steht, der Bruch,
dann müsste man doch eigentlich nicht operieren.
Dann könnte man doch konservativ behandeln,
und dann weiß es nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich bin kein Arzt.
Aber ich denke mal, wenn der Bruch jetzt nicht verdreht ist,
oder wenn es keine Fehlstellung gibt,
wenn der eigentlich stabil steht,
und dann nur durch die osteoporosen Riss drin ist,
dann müsste es doch eigentlich gehen,
dass man das konservativ behandelt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht.
Ein Vorschlag, ein Gedanke.
Ja, könnte sein, aber in diesem Alter
ja auch diese Knochenheulung ist auch nicht so ordentlich.
Stimmt, natürlich ja.
Langsam und ja...
Da wird er möglicherweise,
würde er zum Pflegefall werden der Patient.
Das ist die Geschichte.
Der Patient ist sehr alt.
Ja.
Bei der Patient wird immer operative behandelt.
Okay, danke.
Wenn der Patient,
für die Patientin Arturus,
die Patientin,
die Patientin, totaler Fürstkrenk behandelt,
dann kann der Patient nicht für die Kartuose,
oder sollte er die Partie behandeln.
Danke schön.
Das sollen wir sowieso durchführen.
Das ist ein einziger Experiment.
Okay, das ist...
Herr Doktor,
könnte Sie bitte sagen,
Fraktur unsichere und sichere Seinen.
Gute Hinweise, ja.
Einer hat ja schon gesagt,
ein sicheres Zeichen hat er gesagt.
Ein sicheres Zeichen heute.
Unsichere Seinen sind
Schwerlung, Überwärmung, Rötung
und Bewegung, Einschränkung.
Sicherer Zeichen sind Krebsation,
Fälschstellung und hatologische Beweglichkeit
und offene Fraktur.
Offene Fraktur, ja.
Okay.
Sicher und unseherer Fraktur.
Das ist eine klassische Prüferfrage.
Danach fragen die.
Sicherer und unseherer Frakturzeichen.
Habe ich schon mehrfach gehört.
Das ist sicherlich gut,
sich diesen Katalog klarzumachen.
Und letztendlich die Entscheidung
für so einen Patienten
würde ich sagen,
würden ja die Orthopäden stellen.
Offensichtlich Dr. Murma, sind Sie Orthopäde?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Ach, ist das schön, wenn man Fachleute an Bord hat.
Sehr gut, ja.
Wunderbar. Danke für Ihren Beitrag.
Ja, das ist doch gut.
Gut, ja, dann bin ich gespannt,
ob das auskommt.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, wie es Herrn Müller geht.
Und dann
müssten Sie
Ihnen gegebenenfalls ja für die OP auch aufklären.
Und die Anästhesisten müssten das Gespräch führen.
Gut, dann
wie gesagt, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden
über Ihren Patienten.
So, jetzt
Ihre
Präsentation.
Da war ein bisschen,
was habe ich mich gewundert.
Und zwar, ich guck mal so der Reihe nach.
Genau.
Und zwar, ich meine,
Sie haben gesagt, die Osteroporose
hat er seit fünf Jahren,
aber gesagt, er hat die seit 15 Jahren.
Kann ein Hörfehler sein,
bei mir oder bei Ihnen?
Ich weiß nicht, was haben Sie aufgeschrieben, Herr Doktor?
Nee, nee, nee, das habe ich ja noch fünf
geschrieben, aber...
Ja, also tatsächlich 15 Jahre, ne?
Dann...
Trombose, wieviel Jahre?
Das war natürlich mal nicht.
Was mich dann gewundert hat,
Sie haben gesagt, die Mutter...
Also, das war bei der Anamnöse
natürlich eine irre Frage
zu fragen, ob die Eltern noch leben.
Der Mann ist selber froh, dass er noch lebt.
Und da kann man nicht gut nach den Eltern fragen.
Da kann man nur fragen, gab es in Ihrer Familie
eine schwere Erkrankung oder schwerwiegende Erkrankung?
Und der Vater ist nicht an Demenz gestorben,
hat er zumindest nicht gesagt.
Der hat gesagt, der Vater ist bis ins Rohalter.
Hat er nichts gehabt?
Ich denke, der ist ein Alterschwächer gestorben.
Ja, was auch immer. Er hat nichts gesagt.
Da können Sie ihm keine Demenz andichten.
Gut, die Mutter mit dem Mammarkatzel um,
das ist klar gesagt.
Dann...
Ja, vegetative Anamnese haben Sie
eigentlich nicht viel gefragt.
Wir haben nach Verdauung und...
Viel über Verdauung und Appetit.
Gewichtsverlust.
Er hat den Husten angegeben.
Dass er immer so trockenen Husten hat.
Und...
Die...
OPs haben Sie benannt.
Genau.
Was Sie der obere Ärzte nicht verraten haben,
das waren die...
Das haben Sie erst auf Nachfrage gesagt.
Diese Hypostesie.
Und in dem rechten Bein.
Und die Bewegungseinschränkung aufgrund der Schmerzen.
Er hat gesagt, er kann in den Sehen wackeln,
aber er kann das Bein eigentlich nicht bewegen.
Insofern,
das hätten Sie eigentlich ihr spontan sagen müssen.
Ja.
Und...
Ja, Differenzialdiagnosen, würde ich sagen, war vollständig.
Und Maßnahmen war,
meine ich, auch soweit komplett.
Was die...
Was die hier noch angegeben haben,
Druckschmerz über der Hüfte.
Druckschmerz über der Hüfte bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Wobei, ja, da wird sich schon...
Das ist vielleicht...
Und...
Und Colorit, colorit, Rötung,
beziehungsweise Blauverfärbung schon durch Hematome.
Wobei der sich natürlich keinen Gefallen getan hat,
indem er nochmal ordentlich Aspirin hinterhergenommen hat.
Weil der damit seine Gerinnung nochmal weiter untergehauen hat.
Das ist...
Ja, vielleicht auch so eine so eine Geschichte.
Das haben Sie auch gesagt,
man muss die Blutwerte auf alle Fälle auf Berennungen untersuchen.
Weil der eben jetzt relativ kurz
vor der OP nochmal ordentlich Aspirin reingenommen hat.
Okay.
Gut.
Ja, wir haben ein paar Baustellen haben wir noch gehabt.
Ich würde also sprachlich glaube ich haben Sie eigentlich
nicht so große Probleme.
Sie konnten sich mit den Patienten gut verständigen
und die Anamnese war auch ja ziemlich konsequent.
Und im Bericht halt ein bisschen auf Vollständigkeit achten.
Das kann ich Ihnen nur jetzt für übermorgen ans Herz legen.
Ja, und ansonsten hoffe ich mal,
dass Sie in Fall kriegen, wo Sie locker und leicht mit zurechtkommen,
dass Sie nicht so einen alten, knatterigen Patienten haben,
der Ihnen so viel erzählt,
sondern dass Sie jemanden...
Das ist für mich immer schwer.
Ich war in der drei Rechnung, das ist die Name.
Ja, Sie haben das lieber,
dass Sie die Leute fragen können.
Der hat ja nun viel erzählt.
Und Sie mussten praktisch das Programm,
was er gesagt hat, mussten Sie schon in Ihre offenen Fragen
eigentlich übernehmen.
Das ist immer die Schwierigkeit.
Aber wir wissen natürlich nicht,
wen Sie, was Sie für einen Patienten kriegen.
Kann alles passieren.
Wir hoffen, dass es keine Hindernisse auf dem Weg gibt.
Und dass das alles gut klappt.
Übermorgen halten wir die Daumen.
Und alle anderen sehen wir am Donnerstag wieder.